gym casanova expert en stratégie en
communication passer par de nombreux
ministères notamment
bonjour j mme casanova merci de répondre
à nos questions sur arte france on a
entendu bassin chebbi trois scénarios
possibles sur la table à quoi s'attendre
ce soir selon vous vous avez un
pronostic je n'ai pas de pronostic vous
savez le jeu du temps médiatique nouveau
ça n'est plus d'être le premier à dire
ce qui se passe mais d'arriver à dire ce
qui va se passer avant que cela se passe
c'est un jeu très risqué et qui présente
peu d'intérêt
d'autant qu emmanuel macron est dans la
situation d'un président de la vème
république c'est à dire que l'ensemble
de la décision est centralisé autour
d'une seule personne et comme il l'a dit
à l'occasion de sa campagne électorale
ce qu'il fait ce qu'il veut restaurer en
france c'est la parole du roi
alors vous imaginez qu évidemment tout
l'intérêt consiste à ne pas avouer avant
ce qu'il va dire
c'est pourquoi l'exercice de gabriella
talent par exemple a été un exercice de
communication mais pas un exercice de
politique
françois mitterrand avait coutume de
dire la politique c'est dire des choses
à des gens gabriel à thann a fait
exactement inverse il a absolument rien
dit pendant tout le cours de sa
conférence de presse pour bien réserver
l'exclusivité du propos et de l' annonce
un président dont vous savez qu'il aime
parler longuement puisqu'aucun président
de la vème république n'a parlé autant
que lui et dans des discours qui souvent
comporte moins d'informations que de
mise en valeur de ses propres
compétences capacités ou talent je
savoure donc on parle beaucoup de
communication vous êtes expert en
communication politique vous êtes
expérience stratégie politique comment
est ce que vous allez analyser la
communication et la stratégie d'
emmanuel macron on le rappelle le
président la semaine dernière à l'issue
de la première journée du conseil
européen qui a
estimé avoir eu raison de ne pas re
confiné fin janvier il y a deux aspects
d'abord le président s'est laissé aller
à son naturel et il est donc apparu aux
français et même aux journalistes qui
lui sont la plupart du temps favorable
comme arrogant en disant finalement j'ai
eu toujours raison sur tout évidemment
on a ressorti des extraits de ce qu'il
avait dit quand il a dit en novembre
décembre que lille et qui est un axe
awad mars était une idée absurde et et
d'autres considérations de ce type sa
situation n'est pas extrêmement facile
comme toute personne sur qui repose
comme sur une tête des pagnes toute la
décision d'autant que si vous avez
remarqué depuis le début de la crise
legrand éléments pris en compte par les
dirigeants et l'exécutif se sont les
procès qui pourront suivre la crise
sanitaire est la question clé dans ses
process et celle du tri des malades
toute famille dont le patient serait
mort parce qu'il aurait été triés
négativement va être fondés à faire une
procession procédure longue et qui peut
mettre dans les pires difficultés les
responsables politiques qui se trouvent
aux affaires on a vu alors justement du
tri des malades une ligne rouge
également c'est ce qu'a dit bruno le
maire
hier le tri des malades on en parle
beaucoup le corps hospitalier on parle
beaucoup mais depuis un an qu'est ce
qu'on a retenu justement par rapport par
rapport à ça
des lits supplémentaires n'ont pas été
créés entre juin et maintenant on se
retrouve face à ça non on a supprimé les
lie depuis le dernier confinement on a
en france supprimé des lits d'hôpitaux
on a poursuivi la politique menée depuis
trente ans de réduction du format de nos
hôpitaux on a supprimé des lits et on a
supprimé des personnels donc
naturellement la question est plus vive
à l'automne est plus vive encore
maintenant et c'est lorsqu'elle se
présente sous l'angle de tri les malades
que les médecins ne veulent pas avoir de
procès et qu'ils exigent un confinement
absolue mais dont l'exécutif c'est
maintenant pour avoir lu les documents
de l'om est-ce que c'est lorsqu'on est
enfermé que le virus se propage le plus
et qui vaut mieux donner de l'air pour
que le virus se propage moins donc on
est arrivé à une situation très
difficile pour l'exécutif qui pour ne
pas avoir voulu renoncer à la diminution
du nombre de lits se trouve maintenant
en position de faire des dépenses
extrême pour arriver à compenser il
reste tout de même des milliers de lits
d'hospitalisation privé auquel on n'a
pas fait appel
ou très peu l'an dernier auxquels on
pourrait commencer à faire appel on est
là en face d'un système administratif
français qui a ses lourdeurs et ses
tabous et qui préfèrent faire traverser
le pays à des malades et donc de les
mettre dans un hôpital privé quelques
kilomètres une question pour revenir sur
la communication comme vous êtes expert
en communication gilles casanova on est
le 31 mars
si on se souvient bien on remonte un
petit peu en arrière le 1er mars donc il
ya quatre semaines emmanuel macron il
avait dit il faut encore tenir quatre à
six semaines ça fait donc quatre
semaines alors certes il faut encore
attendre deux semaines pour arriver au
aussi semaine finalement le bout du
tunnel
il est où à la fois concrètement parlant
j'ai envie de dire scientifiquement
parlant même si vous n'êtes pas
scientifique mais mais médiatiquement
parlant et par rapport à cette crise
elle est où aller ou la fin il faut
fixer un calendrier et un cap pour les
français qui commence à en avoir marre
quand même si l'on regarde nos voisins
anglais qui grâce aux breaks site ont eu
la liberté de s'approvisionner comme il
l'entendait en termes de vaccins ils ont
maintenant ils sont passés en dessous de
25 morts par jour c'est à dire un seuil
qui est très très inférieurs dix fois
moins que celui de la france donc on
peut penser que si on avait une
politique de vaccination comparables
mais il veut le faudrait pour ça avoir
acheté des vaccins et la france a décidé
de ne pas acheter de vaccins et de
confier son sort à bruxelles donc la
date elle est liée à ce que bruxelles
voudra bien faire le commissaire
bruxellois français d'ailleurs breton a
indiqué qu' il pensait au 14 juillet
comme date à laquelle on pourrait
considérer que le virus l'épidémie son
contenu vous riez que ce n'est pas
quatre à six semaines
le problème de communication du
président acron c'est qu'il est entre
deux exigences celle du président qui
veut protéger les français celle du
candidat qui ne veut pas déplaire aux
français les deux choses ne sont pas les
mêmes au bout d'un an ou les français
sont excédés de mesure pas toujours
facile à comprendre
vous sortez vous avez droit à faire 10
km mais si vous êtes avec votre chien
vous n'avez plus qu'à droit qu'à un
kilomètre mais si vous avez votre panier
pour faire vos courses vous pouvez 30 km
mais quand vient le soir vous ne pouvez
plus du tout sortir sauf si vous avez le
chien et là vous pouvez encore faire un
kilomètre
ça c'est bien pour des énarques mais
beaucoup de français n'ont pas passé
l'ena et on sentiment que ça devient
trop compliqué beaucoup de gendarmes et
de policiers aussi d'ailleurs
dernière question rapidement il nous
reste moins d'une minute
une casanova demain il ya le premier
ministre jean castex qui est va
prononcer une déclaration au sujet de la
crise sanitaire au sujet de la
déclaration ce soir d'emmanuel macron
elle sera suivie d'un débat et d'un vote
devant les deux chambres du parlement
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat
ça veut dire quoi que les élans les
annonces ce soir d'emmanuel macron
seront suspendus au vote des
parlementaires de demain c'est ça il n'y
a plus un seul homme qui décide c'est ça
c'est pas une tradition d'un cinquième
république c'est encore moins la
tradition des manuels macron où le
parlement est une chambre
d'enregistrement puisqu'ils votent
régulièrement la possibilité pour le
gouvernement de gouverner par
ordonnances je crois qu'il s'agit d'un
moment de communication où l'exécutif va
essayer de ne pas avoir un vote topo
style ses décisions merci gilles
casanova d'avoir répondu à nos questions
je rappelle que vous êtes expert en
stratégie et en communication politique